welcome to studio playing dodgy from the
UK I wonder did I play min in sim yours
maybe so it rings a bell ok let's go for
the Queens gambit oh the kettle on ok
I'm playing the clothes catalan if I
have some ideas with that opening let's
see if I can get something on the board
that I analyzed some time ago with
bishop a6 rook c8 and stuff like that ok
yeah that's black side da with the
closed Catalan you try to get some play
against c4d for row that's sharp and at
stake and the rookie say opposed to the
Queen which is quite off meeting to
tactical ideas
hmm what is he doing here he 50 yeah if
I've one interesting move now sd3 try to
gain tempe now g4s also interesting
let's do this that's an interesting move
94 is now just losing basically yeah and
here this is interesting i was thinking
i can take and how would the ç teague
now nine texas be five yes so that's not
not on stand Bishop c5 if that was an
ATM trying to undermine the e5 pawn
yeah I thought Quincy seven maybe trying
to take that just being greedy look if
you didn't think of that move it's not
bad of course okay mmm taking on f 2 is
this somehow better than usual I mean
normally it is bad so hmm Wow didn't
really see that move coming night h6 I
mean it's not as bad as it looks I hope
I just got 95 huh night f5 g44 should be
seven
well what a shaky game what a shaky game
maybe you can take age seven or
something yeah it's still not completely
clear this position however I clearly
played some some very questionable moves
just move that ok 93 maybe the tavern
you will take f5 can I can I move it
like to edge form very Viet I mean the
position is still not that clear at
least I think because well wideouts I
have some problems the bishop on a one
is bad and so on g-form or that i am not
sure about it I probably worse somehow
or maybe maybe more but it's not like
super easy maybe 95 said a move maybe
yeah lat g5 I was just thinking about it
Knight f6 mother was a threat so what is
he doing now taking here man i think i
should probably kept keep this keep this
night on d3 that also sometimes i have
night f4 yeah yeah f9f for i think
wow that's a totally irritating position
nobody knows what's going on here
it feels I should be okay somehow but
don't don't really I don't really
understand anything here is there some
threat here do I threaten something
maybe I threatened to take on g5 and
play a queen e 7 or something like that
this is probably a threat here if the
night moves that I have night age 3 whoa
so he says that I cannot take this
because of this Knight f6 business okay
let's let's close that diagonal and ng2
is hanging so here we go again so
probably move the rook but where exactly
on the second I guess
so now Keeks and or queen d8 maybe queen
Jaime 28 it's not bad i think just
attacking g5 twice oh I have plenty of
rooks Jack this is also not bad check
check white resign yeah somehow I don't
know he wriggled myself out of that it
is probably probably was kind of lost
okay this disposition is some junk shop
just shop he took there and then went
went with this yeah now simply I simply
did not register Queenie for as a as a
move the engine is giving f5 which I've
thought about briefly I thought that
this should be interesting but I didn't
want to spend lots of time on that and
then register that it's not working or
whatever or I lose on dive at the end
computer says equal yeah whatever that
means I mean I'm certainly very active
here with the night here Bishop here but
I'm also porn down very difficult to say
how bad was the game night here 95g for
who should be seven that that was
necessary he took it here and went back
to be one yeah I don't know it's a
difficult to say maybe Quincy to as bad
I am covering the night or so okay i
played this and he went Knight f3 yeah
and the engine is giving GTX sticks
Luke Teague's and f6 this was also more
what I had on the raid 0 g 6 is the
engine move now you have to play this
first yeah i mean i understand that it
keeps things relatively closed it's
funny that the engine is giving equal
but i don't really trusted him after a
couple of seconds because it can easily
happen that white has some kind of
attack that is currently out of the
horizon for the comp it looks very
dangerous maybe lost night here yeah I
know I'm better neither three really
didn't didn't do the job and 93 I know
black black just wins just wins is a
relative it's not easy oh I could have
taken on e5 in this position I didn't
consider that move but this seems ok I
really and yeah it wins as well peanut
was strong no yeah no black chad is
doing the chat full-scale invasion yeah
i could have probably gotten a big
advantage at one point but it was never
that's that simple right here this one
here
yeah probably really here yeah yes to
take I grabbed the night and and this
the engine as I said it just gives like
0.4 something but I have my doubts that
this is just that this might be too low
and what is even much better here I find
this is very likely actually but okay I
cannot now do this for five minutes and
and get to clear a conclusion I think in
a practical game white has excellent
winning chances at least thanks for
watching